Democratic presidential candidate Robert
O'Rourke known to many as Beto O'Rourke
has exited the presidential race he's
been most recently polling just under
two percent on average this is pretty
logical Beto has not gotten traction
like many other candidates he's not
gotten traction he's decided to exit the
race because he recognizes that quote we
do not have the means to pursue this
campaign successfully nothing to laugh
at
he's recognizing something that other
candidates are either not recognizing or
not willing to accept publicly now
Donald Trump immediately continuing with
his dog rhetoric saying that Beto has
quit like a dog which doesn't really
make any sense
if anything it confirms Donald Trump
doesn't really know anything about dogs
the dogs certainly not known for the
trait of quitting things in fact the
word dogged meaning having tenacity or
persistence suggests the opposite
although I have no idea I know that
dogged contains the og but I have no
idea if the etymology is actually from
the word dog anyway maybe that's me
making a joke maybe it's not if it works
then by all means dogged meaning having
tenacity how weird is it though what's
going on with Donald Trump and dogs Isis
leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi died like a
dog
according to Trump not sure how many dog
deaths Trump has witnessed maybe
something to look into
Beto or Rourke quit like a dog just very
strange dog imagery now that Donald
Trump changed his residency to Florida
the headlines could be Florida man
screams at presidential candidate about
dogs and it would be a sort of accurate
the upside to Trump using dog as his
newest insult is that he's far less
likely to misspell it when he tweets
about it I don't think that this is all
bad though better or getting out I have
been saying for several weeks it's time
to start trimming down the field and
getting some of the people that don't
have a shot out of the race I would love
to see better or work specifically as
I've said before go back to Texas and
challenge Republican Senator John Cornyn
for a Senate seat even if you can't
defeat Cornyn I don't know
maybe he could but even if he can't
forcing Republicans to have to spend a
bunch of money in that race would be a
really great thing and speaking of which
there are several people polling around
two percent the way better O'Rourke has
been who should also quit Delaney is at
0.3% I don't even know if he's still
running I thought maybe he did drop out
marianne williamson is at 0.4% she
should go
who Leon Castro sadly because I think
he's actually a much better candidate
than a lot of the others polling noting
is that 0.6 percent probably time for
him to leave
Bennett again I thought Bennett was out
I guess he's still in he's at 0.7
percent Tom Steyer at just under 1% is
truly an annoying annoyance Cory Booker
and Tulsi Gabbard at 2% time to go guys
it's over and then Amy Klobuchar and
Andrew yang between two and a half and
three percent
they're probably ending soon but they
can maybe justify staying for one more
debate because they are listen three is
not that far from five and then you're
in kamala territory so maybe they can
justify staying in notably in the last
week this is just a week but in the last
week Bernie back up Joe Biden back up an
Elizabeth Warren down sort of reversing
the recent trends it's good not to go
too far into analyzing the ways polls
move in just one week because this is a
long race currently we have nine people
qualified for the fifth debate that's
later this month on November 20th we
have gathered in Castro pending
qualification if they can get the
polling they need they've hit their
fundraising requirements so that's that
I applaud Beto for being realistic and
doing what makes sense and I would like
to see him go back to Texas and at least
fight for the Senate seat currently held
by John Cornyn let me know if you think
that's a good idea I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman follow me on Twitter I'm very
close to a hundred thousand followers
and it would be amazing to reach that
completely arbitrary and meaningless
round number so that then we can try to
reach some larger arbitrary round number
follow me on Twitter at D Pakman and
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show the david pakman show is
possible thanks to sponsors like VIN
chair
watch's giving everyone in our audience
15% off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch I just got
a couple of new watches from these guys
and I love them I got the Kairos limited
release gold reserve set which is very
cool I love the white face the simple
band and everything about it it's a
perfect size for my wrist really great
choice I also picked out the Ventura
bellwether in silver and white and what
I love about this one number one
the Roman numeral at the top of the face
the white face is great this is a
chronograph model and I love the blue
leather band it's just a really nice
looking watch everybody who sees me wear
this one always asks about it what I
like about Vince arrow as a watch brand
is you're getting quality and you're
getting a watch where it's clear as soon
as you open the box that a lot of care
and artisanship went into the design and
the way that the watch is put together
I'm not interested in paying thousands
of dollars for a watch when I can get
one that's reasonably priced and looks
just as nice and has terrific build
quality and that's exactly what Vince
arrow is in the business of doing
putting a ton of craftsmanship into
their watches making them available for
a hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
you really can't go wrong check them out
at david pakman.com slash watch support
the people who support our show and
you'll save fifteen percent when you use
that link